[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
what a Prof hi Martin we're continuing
with purified seven times and what an
interesting first episode we had last
week well let's hope this one ties it
together somewhat yeah well maybe people
are a little bit more confused or so
hopefully this will bring it all
together I hope so so let's open with a
word of prayer and get into this I
heavenly father thank you again for
bringing us together yes this is for the
most important discussions because it
has to do with your word so please
enlighten our minds and like you said
please protect the word and purify it in
Jesus name amen
amen well Martin purified seven times
was our
topic here's a quote from from here to
Forever while Luther was opening a
closed Bible to the people of Germany
Tindle was impelled by the spirit of God
to do the same for
England wickliff Bible had been
translated from the Latin text which
contained many
errors that puts it in a nutshell right
the cost of manuscript copies was so
great that it had a narrow
circulation all it actually did was
create a hunger for the word that's it
and I was just thinking here she clearly
states that the vgate is full of Errors
full of Errors
yes so wickliff didn't have anything
else because the other manuscripts
hadn't arrived in in Europe in 1516 for
the first time the New Testament was
printed in the original Greek tongue
many errors of former versions were
corrected and the sense was more clearly
rendered so this clearly shows us that
the received text from which they were
derived is the one that corrected the
errors that's
it it led many amongst the educated to a
better knowledge of Truth and gave a new
impetus to the work of Reform but the
common people were still to a great
extent de God from God's word Tindle was
to complete the work of wickliff in
giving the Bible to his countrymen he
translated it into English using these
manuscripts but he didn't have it all so
it wasn't fully purified but it was a
lot better yeah then the purification
seven times took place and after the
Geneva Bible eventually you had The
Bishop's Bible and then you had the King
James which was meticulously
translated just to bring it back just to
make it clear it that not matter what or
who King James was he just gave the
authority to translate the Bible yes and
there are many stories about King James
whether they are true or whether they
are not true is immaterial he did at
some stage write a document in which he
expounded on the papacy as the
Antichrist mhm so that is the other side
of the story but it was the
reformers that actually did the
translation now Martin Luther's story
began of course with his protest against
indulgences mhm and he wrote 95 thesis
and nailed them to the church door at
vitberg and this is where the War Began
because you're touching a do of Rome
yeah namely Purgatory which is not
biblical and it brought a lot of money
and it brought a lot of money and Martin
Luther questioned whether this was right
or whether it was not right and today if
you go to vittur here on the church door
his 95 thesis are still there to be read
they only dealt with indulgences not
with the other doctrines of Rome at all
and of course poor Martin Luther had
chastised himself and created or
performed many penances when he was a
monk when he was a monk because he
couldn't find relief and when he studied
the book of Romans first of course in
the Latin manuscripts but even there he
discovered that the papacy couldn't be
right in its doctrine of
salvation and he then got hold of these
new
manuscripts and God created the
circumstance whereby he could translate
it into the German tongue which wasn't
an easy job because there was so many
dialects and he took all the dialects
and created basically a unified language
which is called high German and that was
used from then on yes and Tindle did the
same with English so Tindle really is
responsible more than the people say
Shakespeare and others for creating the
Modern English language
and then of course he was eventually
banned or hid in the v book at isak
which today is the UNESCO world heritage
center and there he had the
opportunity to translate the Bible into
German and here's a a quote from the
book romanism and the Reformation by
Graton Guinness and it says Luther
writes in answer to the pope Rome has
cut herself off from the universal
church if you reform not I and all that
worship Christ to account your seat to
be possessed and oppressed by Satan
himself to be the Damned seat of
antichrist which we will not be subject
to nor incorporate with but do detest
and abhor the same and there's a little
plaque there which says got v l shrift
is this pops on Calvin's
gift which means Martin that's God's
word and Luther's writing are the popes
and Calvin's
poison so Martin Luther didn't always
agree with Calvinism either and there
are some interesting posters of that
time where you find Martin Luther
pulling the hair of the Pope and
plucking at the beard of Calin so there
were some issues there now remember that
the Geneva Bible had calvinistic
subscripts those were also removed later
in the King James version yes yeah now M
it's possible to have a true and a false
gospel
right it's a promise actually it says in
the word that will there will be false
christs bringing false gospels
Revelation 14:6 and I saw another Angel
flying in the midst of Heaven having the
Everlasting ing gospel to preach unto
them that dwell on the earth and to
every nation and Kindred tongue and
people so if at the end the Everlasting
gospel must be preached again to
humanity it has already been done then
it means that it was sort of lost and
had to be repr preached but you need the
right word of God in order to do
that 2 Corinthians 11:4 warned us for if
he that cometh preaches another Jesus
whom we have not preached or if you
receive another Spirit which we have not
received or another gospel which we have
not accepted you might as well bear with
him so what he's saying it's possible to
preach another Jesus one that didn't die
for you it's possible to receive another
spirit that says you don't have to
repent yeah because the true spirit will
convict you of sin it's possible to
receive another gospel where you are
saved by works and not by the
righteousness of Christ is that right
yeah so Galatians 1:6 says I Marvel that
you also soon removed from him that
called you into the grace of Christ unto
another gospel is it possible to preach
salvation by works rather than salvation
by the imputed and imparted
righteousness of Christ oh for sure and
it can happen easily because it says
yeah he Marvels as how soon it happened
to them yes verse 7 says which is not
another but there be some that trouble
you and would pervert the gospel of
Christ it happened in his days yeah so
how much more later so let's just go
through that alexandrian
stream the left the one that's on the
left and on the right the one that is
the groundwork for paple
Doctrine well there was a school in
Alexandria it was an AR pain school
could almost call it an occult School of
gnostics
yeah and one of the leading figures
there was
Oregon and he lived from 185 to
253 after
Christ now Oregon being a
gnostic uh perverted the scriptures yeah
and it changed the
wording so that Christ would not be as
Divine as the scriptures pointed him out
to be she made him a little bit less yes
and from early on there were
altercations where people called him an
apostate and of course you had the
stream that went through Antioch and
Syria the Syrian stream and the pasita
Bible for example which was the received
text and here are these manuscripts
which have many Gnostic changes so that
is making Christ a creator being making
him less than what he is yes and from
that stream we jump to 260 to
340 in the time of
Constantine where the Roman Emperor
adopted a form of
Christianity but his coin had Mitra on
the one side and the cross on the other
side and he was associated with eus of
cesaria now Yus was a bishop MH and
Constantine instructed him to create an
ecumenical
Bible which would bring the Heathen into
Christianity so it was a compromised
Bible if you like and uh to call it an
ecumenical Bible is probably correct now
youus was a follower of Oregon yeah so
he put together a number of manuscripts
and eventually there were about 5050 of
these
manuscripts and two of the remaining
ones are probably associated with the
vaticanus and the
cicus now the next step was Jerome
Jerome was a follower of Oregon yeah so
he also had these
leanings and he took these manuscripts
probably from
youus and translated the original Greek
into
Latin that is the
Vulgate that the papacy declared
infallible and made the standard for
Roman Doctrine okay the Vulgate is the
one that says that Mary crushes the head
of the serpent okay that M yes and not
Christ and many many changes that are in
line with Catholic theology rather than
Protestant
theology then you had the Ottoman Empire
and then the Turks that
invaded uh the west and invaded first of
course the Greeks mhm and the Greek
Scholars with their Greek manuscripts of
the received text yeah that came via the
Antioch and uh Syrian line through to
the West Via these scholar
and arasmus of
rdam a Roman Catholic bishop just took
the manuscripts and put them into order
and this was called then the received
text he made the copies of the Greek New
Testament okay now arasmus never became
a Protestant he was very close to
becoming a Protestant he stayed a
Catholic and was even offered to be a
cardinal but he refused so he was a he
was a bit of a fence sitter yeah yeah
yeah he was a bit of a fence sitter but
he never he never wrote the documents he
merely put them together as they came
across from these Greek
Scholars and these documents were then
used by Martin Luther to translate the
New Testament into German based on the
original
Greek now between between the time of
arasmus and the writing of the New
Testament into the normal tongue German
and by Tindle into English we fast
forward to the time of tient off who
lived from 1815 to
1874 now what is
interesting that the Roman Catholics in
order to counter the Bible of the
Reformation yes the Jesuits came
together and they wrote the Jer Bible
yeah because it was written at Jer
that's why it's called the je Bible and
the jei Bible of course is based on the
vaticanus MH and the alexandrian and
Western manuscript that was to counter
the Bible of the Reformation which was
basically the King James by that
time and the German Luther Bible and any
translation that came out of the
Protestant pens yeah of and out of the
of the received text out of the received
text and there was a big war about it
and they tried to convince the world
that these manuscripts were not the best
and the only example they had was this
mutilated vaticanus that didn't have
Genesis in it and didn't have Revelation
in it and then in
1844 very
fortuitous tiend who happened happened
to be a
Protestant found a document in a waste
paper Basket in St Catherine's Monastery
at Sinai yeah the Catholic version of
Sinai and this document was then
compared to the vaticanus and found to
be from the same stable and it was
declared to be a fourth Century document
a pure rendition of the original
biblical text but it had hundreds and
hundreds of
emissions and uh mutilation yeah it was
some places Rewritten like 70 times over
and over again but the interesting thing
is Martin that it was found in
1844 just the time of the Great
Awakening and the Advent Awakening
1844 and the interesting is that this
project Protestant dedicated this find
to the
papacy and the papacy was of course
elated because now a second document
could be added to the
Vatican both of them
mutilated both of them
containing uh apocryphal books of
absolute nonsense but these were the new
oceans of
Purity and tendor then wrote out this uh
document in the Greek and this became
the version that they claimed was the
oldest because it came from the 4th
Century if I'm remember correctly Tish
andorf found it in 1844 but it still
wasn't complete or anything and then he
went back he went back a few years later
and found the rest as well yeah and
collated it now they had two
documents then two
professors from the Protestant schools
of Oxford and Cambridge of course West
cotton
Hort took these documents the vaticanus
and the cicus and put together the Greek
text of
1881 and this Greek text of
1881 then became the basis of all new
translations they are in harmony again
with the Vatican so we've gone full
circle that's it we've gotten rid of the
errors in the vaticanus to return to the
errors of the
vaticanus now westcot and H were
Protestants but they belonged to secret
societies and they were spiritualists
yeah they belonged to an organization
called the ghostly Guild where they
spoke to Spirits yeah and another member
of their illustrious Society was Charles
Darin so we have the whole package of
apostasy together there they also
created and wrote The Secret doctrines
of an organization called the
apostles uh where they wrote the rituals
and the secret Maneuvers and handshakes
and everything that they had that went
along with it and the West cotton H text
became the basis of all modern
translations
now the interesting thing is that there
are thousands of words missing that you
find in the receive text for example in
fact some of the modern versions have up
to
60,000 words fewer than the King James
for example Martin that's like taking
your
Bible and saying how many words are
missing well if you open your Bible and
you open it in Corinthians
I so want to see how thick it is and you
go to the Book of Revelation that's how
much would be missing me just also see
how
th oh no it's more than this
side that's how much is missing
right now the interesting thing is
modern they
say that the originals
that the King James were based on were
inflated
texts they had too many words and too
many repetitions so they took all of
those out now what you've done then is
you've often taken out the second and
the third witness yeah and and not only
that you've destroyed the chayms yes for
example if you go to the Book of
Revelation where it says I am the Alpha
and Omega and then you have more vers
and then it says I am the Alpha and the
Omega sandwiching the kaym in between if
you take out the second one saying it's
a needless repetition you destroy the
kism yeah the emphasis you also destroy
what is called Hebrew
parallelism where a issue is repeated in
order for greater Clarity to but in a
different state in a different way and
then many of the the verses are
literally are removed
and Christ becomes less than he is
exactly and verses are introduced which
introduce the immortality of the soul
verses are introduced which remove
repentance so that it fits Catholic
Doctrine so the westcot and H text
written by these
occultists and these secret society
members which claimed that
mariology was pristine in other words
that's a Catholic sentiment that's why
they could rather have just taken the
Vulgate and they wouldn't have had to do
so much work and they were
dsts they negated the first books of the
Bible so they became higher
critics so these individuals as far as
many many people is concerned and myself
included as far as I'm concerned were
Jesuits in Disguise yeah and I think
agents at the best and Jesuits at worst
that's it and I think Tish andorf was
the also part of that and Tish andorf
was part of the same game now Martin if
the Bible says man does not live by
bread alone but by every word that
proceeds out of the mouth of the Lord
you just took the words out of my mouth
now would you like 60,000 words to be
gone of and M if two verses say the
exact opposite yeah like job saying in
my flesh I shall see God and the new
translation saying in without my flesh I
will see God they can't both be the word
of God no one of them must be
spous if the new translation says
Heavenly beings had sexual relations
with
humanity and the received text says that
those that followed God the the children
of God saw that the childrens of men the
apost that line from Cain they
intermingled so Mar if you have two
lines and the one says in my flesh I
shall see God the received text and the
other one says without my flesh I shall
see God then you have a choice because
they can't both be right
no and uh if the new translations remove
the deity of Christ in many many places
and make him the servant rather than the
sun then that is pretty problematic that
probably has Gnostic influence attached
to it so all of these issues together
together with the fact that they were
higher critics tells me that uh there is
something wrong with it and they admit
in the translations of the new ones that
they are busy with an Eclectic text
explain that as well that means that the
text is Ever Changing
but God said that his word stands and
that you mustn't add to it and you
mustn't subtract to it so how can it be
an everchanging word exactly there's
actually a curse on anybody that does
that correct moreover the modern
versions are what we call Dynamic
equivalent
versions now what is the dynamic
equivalent it means that it is
everchanging and that it is like what
God God said but it is filtered through
the mind of a theologian in other words
it is an expose of what the Theologian
thinks God was saying so it's based on
his
theology now the King James took that
even out of the footnotes of the Geneva
Bible yeah but here it's all the way
back so it's not what God said it's not
a direct translation it's what people
think that God said so you get to ridic
UL situations where Jesus declares all
foods clean when the original text
doesn't say that at all so the Bible
contradicts itself so these are all
issues that need to be addressed and to
be studied so let's just continue this I
just want to say if there is a modern
translation that says it's a direct
translation you have to look from which
manuscripts of course even if it is a
direct translation if it comes from
these manuscripts which come from the
Catholic
line then you have to ask yourself is
this the word of God yeah and obviously
we've seen it cannot be it cannot be so
who's in whose interest is it to change
the theology which organization has a
different theology Rome has that's it it
has a different system of Salvation And
if it wants to sell its system of Sal
salvation how much better to change the
word of God if you take it they wanted
to get rid of the word of God that's why
4,260 years you couldn't you you weren't
allowed to read your Bible right and
then when the King James called came out
they called it that poisonous ass
exactly that they would tread on its
head and destroy it and take it by the
tail like one of Moses's sticks and get
rid of it that's what the Jesuits said
so the Jesuits
have it in mind from the translation of
the DU already to counter the Protestant
Bible yeah because like you said the DU
says that Mary will crush the head and
not Christ and then also in that
1,260 years they couldn't get rid of the
Bible eventually they had to infiltrate
they had to infiltrate so the Jesuits
are there to counter the Reformation so
let's just go a little bit into what
happened there we read in the book The
Great
controversy throughout christiandom
protestantism was menaced by formidable
foes the first triumphs of the
Reformation passed Rome summoned new
forces hoping to accomplish its
destruction at this time the order of
the Jesuits was created the most cruel
unscrupulous and Powerful of all the
champions of popery under various
disguises the Jesuits worked their way
into offices of State climbed up to be
the councilors of kings and shaping the
policy of Nations they became servants
to act as spies upon their masters they
established colleges for the sons of
princes and Nobles and schools for the
common people and the children of
protestant parents were drawn into an
observance of popish Rights That's
History Martin that is fact and you
don't have to read it in the great
controversy you can read it even in the
writings of the presidents of the United
States of America true those that still
were faithful to
scripture here's another source r w
Thompson ex Secretary of the Navy USA he
writes as for Holy
obedience this virtue must be perfect in
every point in execution in will in
intellect doing what is enjoined with
all cerity spiritual joy and
perseverance persuading ourselves that
everything is just suppressing every
repugnant thought and Judgment of One's
Own in a certain obedience and let
everyone persuade himself that he who
lives under obedience should be moved
and directed under Divine Providence by
his Superior just as if he were a corpse
per a kadav aset which allows itself to
be moved and led in any
direction that was the order of the
Jesuits they obeyed the pope like a
corpse they would have no will of their
own and if the pope said something was
white or their Superior said something
was white when it was black then it was
white finish their object was to destroy
the scriptures the old and the New
Testament and they are quite proud of it
as we saw in our one of our previous
lectures here is the
church destroying Calvin and
Luther and this little mischievous
creature here which they call an angel
is tearing apart the
scriptures that Martin Luther gave to
the world so their aim was to destroy
the Protestant
Bible here is another quote from letters
and manuscripts now what does Satan
proposed to do he proposes that he is
capable of changing this
Bible now Martin this was written in
1910 these parties that fell understand
all about heaven this is talking about
demons and they can bring in the
different sentiments from the Bible and
they're going to have a revision of it
interesting written in
1910 you will see that they will make a
revisions of the Bible but every one of
us needs to stand intelligently on the
word we cannot afford to be careless but
we must have that Simplicity of
godliness that is a virtue to us we must
have it now this author mhm was exposed
to some of the early new manuscripts
like the revised
version and she used it sometimes when
it was not doctrinal in nature when it
was doctrinal in nature she always used
the King James version yes but in any
sermon she never deviated from the King
James and the more she wrote and the
closer she came to her end of her life
she never used them anymore that's true
here's another document from 1906 do you
desire to destroy the Covenant between
yourselves and your God a Perpetual
Covenant means just what it says it is a
sign between me and the children of
Israel
forever God declares for in six days the
Lord made the heaven the Earth and on
the seventh day he rested and was
refreshed this is our evidence you will
see ear long that there will be those
who will become weary of hearing
repeated the things that they ought to
do but do not desire to do and they will
change the wording of the Bible they're
written in
1906 we know what the Lord says in
Revelation about those those who do that
a Perpetual Covenant is a Perpetual
Covenant they will change the Bible she
was using the King James Bible yes and
like you said for doctrinal purposes you
can search right through the writings
yes es there in fact are you can SE it
when there's um disputes on certain
verses like we've mentioned Genesis 6:12
where the modern translations um say
that the Heavenly beings came if you do
go through the writings of the spirit of
Prophecy it's clearly stating that that
was the line of Cain and not Heavenly
beings yes and not only that Martin if a
verse is missing in the new translations
which is many times the case sometimes
she wrotes whole paragraphs chapters on
the missing verses true so obviously she
didn't use those to write about the
missing
verses uh Wilkinson in our authorized
Bible Vindicated writes the following we
will gain control of instructions in law
talking about the Jesuits what their
statements are these are quotes of their
statements and that's why I put this
little mischievous creature this demonic
little thing over here that is tearing
the the scriptures of the Protestants
apart in the picture
again we will gain control of
instruction in law
Medicine Science Education and so weed
out from all books of instruction
anything injurious to Roman
Catholicism Martin you cannot trust a
modern encyclopedia they are lying to
you what about the medical world whoa
Martin let's not go there
because they are the ones that
introduced many of the forms of modern
medicine but let's leave that there
before we get into trouble we will mold
the thoughts and ideas of the youth we
will enroll ourselves as Protestant
preachers and college professors West
coton H Perhaps tendor Perhaps what
about God and new yes in the different
Protestant faiths sooner or later we
will undermine the author
of the Greek New Testament of
Erasmus that's the one that the
Protestant Bibles the New Testament is
based on and also of those Old Testament
Productions which have dared to raise
their head against the Old Testament of
the vgate and against tradition and thus
will we undermine the Protestant
Reformation this is what they said now
Martin
Old Testament manuscripts the Old
Testament was based on the mauretic text
yes now Oregon MH wrote a comparison of
different Old Testament writings and he
had one Greek manuscript which is called
the septu the alexx MH uh translated
apparently by 70
individuals and
Oregon says that U
Scholars were invited from
Jerusalem and they sent representatives
from every tribe to translate it firstly
that is illegal because only the Levites
were to be involved in transcribing
manuscripts and in any case the northern
tribes didn't exist at that stage
anymore so it's obviously a lie for a
long time already yes but one of these
columns in in his comparative Old
Testament writings is the
septu they say they will undermine the
Protestant Bible that uses for the Old
Testament the Matic text now they prefer
the septu and they tell you that Christ
used it now there's no evidence of this
septu other than in the writings of
Oregon from the 2 Century who was a
gnostic who was a gnostic
and if you take that one at its word
then Martin we can conclude that
matusalem was a very strong
swimmer correct because he survived the
flood by some 14 years and the only way
if we want to believe that is that he
must have been swimming for 14 years to
survive the flood cuz he wasn't in the
ark Sam there are discrepancies in the
timeline for example if you want to take
the original text the mastic text and
you want to study the timelines you will
get to about 6,000 years for the age of
the Earth true whereas if you take the
seant you are very fluid and you could
end with anything up to 10,000 years so
the timelines are all messed up wouldn't
the Jesuits love something like that of
course we listened to Dawkins what did
he say about the 6,000 years yes now
Martin if the septu was used in the time
of Christ there's no evidence for that
other than their statements so uh is it
really true or not if I'm not mistaken
even if you take the text that they say
he quoted it's not even in the quot the
subagent it's actually in the mastic
text but the fact of the matter is
there's no evidence that it existed in
that time other than that it is in
Oregon's writings so they call it the
missing link because it doesn't exist it
sounds like Evolution yes so as far as
I'm concerned I don't believe that matum
was that strong a swimmer so I prefer to
believe the version that is in the
Protestant Bible amen and the Jesuits
can play as much as they like that
version is available and it's not
copyrighted
it cannot be it cannot because you
cannot copyright God's word yeah all
right Martin so let's have a look at
some interesting
statements let's talk about the
authority of the holy spirit being
replaced with the authority of man
Cardinal hosius who was the president of
the great Council of Trent affirmed that
apart from the authority of the church
the scripture would have no more weight
than the fables of ESOP
that's quite a statement Martin he says
the Bible is like the fables of ESOP if
it weren't for the church they will tell
you what's right in it and what's wrong
in it that's arrogance that's the same
we saw that in the pre um episode it
fits right in with the Antichrist yes
and you know what they use the Bible to
support that in fact they support their
position by invoking 2 Peter 1 verse2
but they totally ignore verse 21
because verse 20 says knowing this first
that no Prophecy of the scripture is of
any private
interpretation so they say they
interpret it for you yeah but verse 21
says for prophecy came not in Old Time
by the will of man but holy men of God
spoke as they were moved by the Holy
Ghost so the prophetic
interpretation is the owness of God who
will Enlighten you with his spirit so
the Holy Ghost is the one that does it
and not the church not the
church in
14818 the Vatican manuscript was
discovered in the Vatican Library this
is a corrupted manuscript which
repeatedly casts aside the deity of
Christ it reflects the aryanism of
Oregon and is thought by some to be one
of the surviving manuscripts done by uus
at the command of Constantine the date
of its writing coincides with the
ecumenical Bible of Constantine this
comes from Les garat which Bible can we
trust well this is what many scholars
believe the CTIC manuscript which was
discovered in
1844 at Mount siai in the monastery of
St Katherine agrees closely with the
Vatican manuscript and minimizes the
deity of Christ and is also Aryan in
nature it is safe to suggest that these
two manuscripts were two of the 50 that
were written for Constantine even though
some people say that they are modern
forgeries so either way they are full of
Errors corrected over and over again but
this is the ocean of Purity that the
modern ones are based
on and the 1881 text of wescot and hawed
this text departed from the Texas
receptors and follows the Vatican and
cicus Corruptions most Scholars from
every spectrum of Christianity have
knowingly or otherwise promoted the
westcot and Hawk from that time to the
present so these Scholars Martin if you
go to the Bible translation committees
they all have Jesuits on them yeah and
they all admit that they are eclectic
texts and that they are Dynamic
equivalent and that we can expect the
changes to come as they discover more
Corruptions introduce them yeah and they
are higher critical
texts so what is this the word of God or
is this something else no it's it's
definitely something else as Garrett
writes who but those with Roman Catholic
sympathies could ever be pleased with
the notion that God preserved the true
New Testament text in secret for almost
1,000 years and then finally handed it
over to the Roman pontiff for SA keeping
it's a very good question isn't that a
good question for sure makes no sense
whatsoever and God gave the Reformation
spous documents to base their theology
on and we really have to go back to
Catholicism and believe that you can
roast in purgatory and beg the pope for
an Indulgence to shorten that
time so westcot and H these two
gentlemen were they true Protestants or
were they Jesuit infiltrators if you
read their own writings I think they
were definitely Jesuit they were
catholic through and through mariology
higher criticism their job was to
denigrate the scriptures to drag them
through the mud they were evolutionists
they didn't believe the word of God but
they claimed that the vaticanus and the
cicus were oceans of purity
they were oceans of mud as far as I was
concerned they were spiritists so they
were in communication with demons yes
they even describe how they were were
frightened when the things started
rattling and moving around in one of
their spiritualistic meetings they were
in communion with
demons these
people so let's wrap this
up we read in the in Bible echo of
1897 man can be exalted only by laying
hold of the merits of a crucified and
Risen Savior the finest intellect the
most exalted Position will not secure
Heaven Martin you cannot bypass
repentance and accepting the
righteousness of Christ you cannot
bypass obedience to God's requirements
you cannot replace repentance with
Penance and then do the same thing over
and over again yeah Satan had the
highest education that could be obtained
this education he received under the
greatest of all teachers that was when
he was in heaven when men talk of higher
criticism when they pass their judgments
upon the word of God call their
attention to the fact that they have
forgotten who was the first and wisest
critic Nam the devil right
he has had thousands of years of
practical experience he it is who
teaches the so-called higher critics of
the world today God will punish all
those who as higher critics exalt
themselves and criticize God's holy word
powerful statement maybe it's a good
warning that I think people must take
note of letters and manuscripts it is
the mind and character of the persons
who study the scriptures that makes the
study
dangerous the difficulties will be
removed from the way of those who search
the scripture with Earnest Humble Hearts
praying to the Lord for wisdom not
asking the church to clarify it for you
no there's to be no cutting out of
scriptures no removing 60,000 words no
removing whole texts and mutilating
others no mutilating the word as
Catholics have done ah so who's behind
it what's behind it who's involved the
Bible is to be searched as a whole the
thing in it hard to be understood will
become plain through the enlightenment
of the holy spirit this is the way to
study the scriptures now modern people
say the King James is too hard to read
with all this thee thou thine etc etc
now even in the time of King James that
was not the common language anymore
everything was you yeah but they decided
to leave it there for the sake of
clarity that's it the Bible is also a
covenant it's a legal document that's
the second portion and as a legal
document it has to have legal writing it
has to be very specific as to who is
being
addressed now when there is a tea
involved like in the thine
thou then it is addressing the
individual when there is a why involved
like in ye in your and you it is
addressing it in the plural the only the
case difference whether it's nominative
accusative or dative the case differs
but it's very specific let me give you
an example Jesus is talking to Nicodemus
he says verily very I say unto thee who
is he addressing Nicodemus Nicodemus T
the the person itself
singular ye must be born again not thou
must be born again ye that means
everybody must be born again so it's
very precise and once you get used to it
you can almost not read the modern ones
because you don't know who it is
referring to
in particular so if you do that same
sentence in the normal talk today verily
verily I say unto you you must be born
again it's gone yeah it's gone so the
Bible has to be searched as a whole the
thing in it hard to be understood will
become
plain through the enlightenment of the
holy spirit so you have to approach your
Bible
prayerfully and once you get used to to
a received text Bible now I'm not a King
James only man but the King James is
based on the received text purified
seven times
times the Luther Bible is based on the
received text the schlak Bible in German
is based on the received text the old
africant version like the 3353 version
that is based on the received text it's
the modern ones that have the verses
missing and have angels mutilating
humanity and all such nonsense in them
so we must decide what do we want to
read so let's leave that decision to
everyone but as for me in my house if I
want to know what did God say and not
did what did the Theologian think you
said and if I want to read every word
that proceeds out of the mouth of the
Lord then I will grab a Bible that comes
comes out of the stable of Protestants
where Christ is exalted as the savior of
the world the Redeemer who will clothe
us with his righteousness yes I am with
you my house is also standing on that
side so let's pray heavenly
father thank you that we have a pure
purified seven times Bible at our
disposal help us us to make use of it to
understand the times we are living in to
understand the prophecies to understand
the Plan of
Salvation that we do not get trapped
into spous doctrines like Purgatory Etc
but that we understand that our
Salvation lies in the only one who has
the power to save because he has life
within himself our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ that is my prayer in Jesus name
amen
[Music]